Oh Oh wouldn't it notice this hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to three retro horror games now
you probably know the developer of these
games or at least you know some of the
games that they've made before they have
made games like power drill massacre
babysitter bloodbath and other games and
her 80s inspired horror movie slash
games so this one that we're gonna start
out with is called nun massacre which I
can only assume doesn't mean that the
nuns are gonna be the ones that are
massacred it is me and the nuns are the
enemy
well maybe not baby maybe see other way
around what am i doing oh I'm taking a
bath oh I'm doing barrel rolls in the
back a little scrub-a-dub-dub in my tub
haha hi another thing about these ones
is that they're deceptively low fidelity
graphics and when I say deceptively I
mean deceptively low it may seem like
it's one of those games that's not
particularly well made I live in a
[ __ ] shiny
oh dear mrs. McDonald I hope this letter
finds you well your child is sick and
needs your immediate attention we would
normally handle this
a second hose in the middle of brilliant
thing right well the roads closed oh oh
can I get around no yeah I can hop over
I don't know if I was supposed to oh
good I have a stamina stamina bar at
least it's pretty robust and not
comparable to what it was before I don't
know why my eyeballs is a VCR recorder
but I'm just gonna let that slide by I'm
assuming that I'm a vlogger back in the
80s don't know where I'm going down to
no more than whether oh there we go as
we do not have a telephone service you
will need to appear in person in a piece
of Christ mother
Apollonia okay I don't know I don't know
why this place is so pup in the
mountains why
oh no the nun massacre I it's good then
there's no massacre it's the nun
massacre non-god massacred including me
now why do I get a climb a mountain rock
climb to be able to get to my kid I
guess way up in the mountains oh hey
there we go thank you mother Apollonia
what
mother mother Apollonia mother Apollonia
whoa wait whoa hey whoa I see somebody I
see somebody hang on a second
who's it oh you're gone oh okay you're
just gone just like that you're just
gone okay I should have sumed in on that
person wait mother mother Apollonia I'm
here wherever here is
I don't remember this in the brochure
how did you build this on this it's a
skyscraper good god what the hell
how'd you do this how do i how do I get
in do I want to get in I don't think I
do all right
mother Apollonia you have got a robust
establishment here filled with many
interesting hit pieces of history but
I'm kind of at a loss I can't see a
front door I don't see a dingdong
doorbell mother of oh hey we found some
hey what is this what are we looking at
I hate it I hate it okay I found it it
was around the side not around the front
where I thought it would have been
mother ellonija oh I hate it oh I hate
it oh I hate everything about it oh this
is
oh no no oh good they've got chains and
wire over the windows for safety
mommy dropped me off at my new school
I'm gonna miss my old friends I brought
Bongo with me though we have a teacher
named sister Euphemia
she has an assistant named sister Kalina
they're teaching us all about Saints and
what wonderful lives they live today we
learned about Saint Lucy her eyes were
put on a plate and she became a martyr
that's a weird word sister
Euphemia said that her love for God
saved her from the evil Romans that
tried to hurt her sister Oh said the
mother of bolonia is gonna take care of
us oh good good good god this is good
I'm glad about this this is good I feel
like this is a good thing barge right in
here Oh they've got TVs just a TV VCR I
needed tape why do I need a tape why do
I need it why do I need a tape I don't
wanna watch anything this is a
confessional booth
[Music]
oh oh oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ]
oh I'm so boned I'm so strongly
incredibly Presley boned
I'm impressively boned Oh what is that
barbed wire pit looks like I'll die he
whoa I think I saw did I see what was I
crazy were you back there where are you
where are you I don't know
open open open open for a tape for a
table look first day I hate sex I hate
this I hate this you go dead you go and
die you could do you go and die just
worry
where are you none none
No
[Music]
I got one blank
I know what to do with this I know what
to do with this I know what to do this I
gotta I got to put this right here and
then I'm a and then I'm good I don't
have my lighter anymore but that's fine
who needs a lighter when you've got foot
spa rock good my first line of defense a
rock map I drew a map so I wouldn't get
lost I'll take the rock though I think
the rock I like the rock rocks good body
rocks good rock real good never mind
just bash my face on that rocks real
good rocks real gun rocks go down first
wait wait wait this is da da this is da
da da they die it's the same place where
that nun was with a nun
ha dad with a demon there was a demon
why is there a demon okay well there's
nothing here so there's no point in
looking for the the demon the demons are
dumb and stupid and no demons oh god I
can't
that way I can't this way I can what is
in here it's a closet why I don't know
ah in here No okay I don't know where I
am
this is the same please it is okay I got
a rock I got a rocking good this why
can't I go up I can't go there we go I
can't go okay okay I can't go up anyway
I need to get oh okay
I just don't know what I'm looking for
Oh what him what what what is what is
map oh I don't need the map there we go
OK ROCK again I've got the rock ok so I
opened this radar oh that's some how
terrifying that somehow more terrifying
I can't see [ __ ] I don't know where I'm
going how are this going where is this
where am I
I don't know I wish I had some light I
just want some light I would do anything
just to get some light whoa wait I mean
this this was locked so it's now not
locked
okay mannequin organ wait wait I just
put away the radar so if I oh I have it
I have it it's a scroll wheel to get it
okay
Oh
wouldn't it notice this
huh oh [ __ ] oh god I didn't know I was
going down here again okay I don't know
how that nun got in the vents but that's
not okay
[Music]
this radars useless this great arse
useless
[Music]
they sure do a good job of making me
feel not safe in these vents boy I'm
glad that they do such a good job of
that that's a great job that they're
doing there about that mm [ __ ] nope
it's not on the radar I don't know what
I'm looking at okay it's a lamp
okay ah oh I see
ah ah mannequin arm I can't carry any
more items well you know what [ __ ] the
radar do me any good
it's sharp okay a steak well okay here
we go back in it no radar radar wasn't
helping anyway I don't know where these
mannequin pieces are supposed to go oh
oh is this what it always looked like I
think yes I think maybe yes
hmm
Oh
I don't want to play anymore oh I don't
want to play this anymore
[Music]
I don't want to lose anymore what is
that
mother Apollonia hates me she pulled me
out of class today but I didn't do
anything I got the ruler five times I
hate it here I can't make friends nobody
wants to talk to me I really don't
believe in God if God was a real thing
wouldn't be many bad people in the world
I miss mommy and my old friends I want
to go home to a normal school yeah yeah
you know I don't think this is a place
for children let alone anybody let alone
me definitely not me I deserve to be in
a better place than this I deserve to be
in a way better place than this I
deserve to be a better place in this
okay that's like that's like oh it's a
god
oh god here comes it's coming here we go
I'm about to be born I'm about to be
royally bonded I'm about to be strongly
boned for something in there junction
box wire need something to cut it that's
probably to the fan oh boy okay
need something to cut that that's good I
don't have nothing ooh a weird operating
table that's not a bed that's not a bed
at all that's if you think that's a bed
you got some issues cuz that's clearly
not bed material oh oh I don't like that
room must be something different behind
there yeah okay okay ah this yeah that's
not an operating table either that's a
dentist chair oh boy who's bad bandages
I can't carry anymore well you know if I
die I die at least if oh god is horrible
at least if I die I don't have to play
his game anymore
I need to pee really bad in class but
mother Apollonia wouldn't listen I
couldn't hold it I try to pee a little
at my desk but she found out everybody
laughs at me I had to clean it up and
walk around in my underwear the rest of
the day
the other kids call me pee pants now I'm
never gonna have friends I'm trying to
pray more if Jesus is watching me but I
feel so alone I don't know what to write
so the end for now yeah a good story a
good story
a child's chair just a chair okay
stretcher for all patient used for
medical purposes yeah this seems like a
nice Hospital it's slowing me into a
sense of security and I don't like that
at all
I don't like that none I don't like none
of it
I like zero of it because it's soon as I
let my guard down
I know that I'm going to
be incredible and I don't want to be
incredible
I would rather not be incredible I think
this leads to bi that back to that room
where the organ was I would rather not
be incredible at this moment I have no
idea what I'm looking for I've got
organs which is weird don't know why but
I've got them
no no wait a minute you didn't tell me
you could do that [ __ ] now shitty tits
oh [ __ ] tits oh [ __ ]
all right you bastard where are you
I'll [ __ ] you just [ __ ] you - [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you I'm going for it [ __ ] you my
guess nothing I guess those easy alright
ok alright there's got to be something
in this ventilation system that I can
use it's gotta be like some other items
something can be done I don't know
what what why give me give me give me
give me give me through no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no oh oh oh oh oh well
well well oh oh oh this is oh wire
clipper let's replace the map with the
wire clipper wait this is good then I
think I know exactly where to go okay so
we do this we're gonna clip the wire
we've got it we go clip it bingo and
Bongo and then we outie
are we out ejust like that okay we've
got that clipped that's good so now we
need to go back to the vent to the vent
wherever the vent was out of don't there
hair then we go back to the vent in the
vent we can go where that fan was let's
go for it baby
let's go for a baby let's go for it baby
baby
I don't know what that's about I don't
know my business my business my business
it's none of my business
none of my I think I think that maybe
might be a bit of uh
[Music]
might be a bit of a problem
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey oh oh my
god okay all right then okay just okay
all right okay
there we go
okay holy [ __ ] all right well that broke
ah and was terrifying
that was terrifying so let's move on to
the next one shall we let's move on to
the next one dude oh man my voice no God
that really thrashed me that was
terrifying except when it broke of
course like it wasn't scary when it
broke but goddamn that was terrifying
all right then well this one's called
feed me Billy so feed me Billy
feed me Billy oh hi okay after drop item
okay so similar thanks her phone yes you
have completed our series you are now
the enlightened
learn it in the ways of your father's
vision
as you know your goals are and observe
its contents you now have your goal well
what's my goal what was my goal well
it's my goal what's what's my goal what
what's my goal what's what's my goal
what is my goal what's my goal never
leave this way never leave through the
front door what's with the weird big
pulsating vagina oh boy Oh feed me Billy
oh you got it buddy
those is dr Lister driving his
driverless drive let's driver and Sewer
go for a drive I think I might have
broken it I might have broken it in the
attempt to shoot a hole because my
problem was I tried to put a hole in a
hole and that's no good for any okay Oh
God
huh I'm not so sure about whatever's
about to happen because I've got a bad
feeling I'm about to murder somebody and
that ain't good for nobody but I gotta
feed the hole in my house and then
father father said that everything was
a-ok that's okay I wasn't gonna you have
a family that's good you keep you keep
family
I like your Goku hair I didn't do what I
just walked up I walked up I don't have
a gardener I didn't I didn't do nothing
I was just you know oh no I'm just gonna
walk okay goodbye goodbye have a good
day I just I like wearing clown masks
nothing wrong with that on a moonlit
night ah dah dah dah dah
[Music]
okay that's that's marginally less
horrible
that's this slightly less horrible
what'd you make me do
why'd you make me do this why'd you make
me do this and this and certainly not
this I can't but don't shake your head
at me like that okay well alright then I
guess we are underway
good okay and cap lunk all right no
one's gonna notice that it's completely
uncovered great oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay oh I know oh boy oh boy okay well
here we go thanks how to put I gotta put
bottle geez I gotta put bodies into the
big ol hole in the ground with teeth Oh
[Music]
two more days
two more days - why
okay I don't know what till but okay
great hello what are you I know what you
do at night I know it's you I know is
you I know
okay great
I love Jazzercise okay
yeah
okay here we go again apparently
I feel bad about my actions I have a lot
of regrets and I think that this is bad
but here I go again
apparently on the same exact stretch of
road that I was at before any tie no
this is different is it different where
am I
I don't know where I am oh hello hi hi
diddly hoho
hello did somebody say burgers oh god oh
god oh god oh boy oh boy
[Music]
oh boy okay well I'm all loaded up I'm
sorry
Oh God why do I do this why am i doing
this why would anybody do this why is
this a thing to do oh boy
okay well load them up I guess oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy okay dub a blog now to blog in
devote into the whole you go one but you
[Music]
another day another murder
ow ow ow ow ow why why would you do that
there was no reason to do that one way
or another
hello yes okay hi how are you doing good
great
I need more I need more I need more okay
you got it buddy
you won't get away with it stupid [ __ ]
who do you think you are I don't know I
don't know who I am I don't think I'm
anybody actually well time to go gotta
get to work the old daily grind you know
how it is you know how it be okay
let's see what we're gonna be doing
today it's a wonderful day in the
neighborhood didn't edit it there hello
um all right
whoa-oh-oh this one got messed up oh
this one's messed up oh all right okay
all right whoa whoa boy pull boil
war boy war boy oh this one's messed up
who is what's not right there's ones now
right this one's definitely not right I
should put it back a guy yes there you
go
time to go all right well what am I
supposed to do with these guys okay
okay all right all right into the hole
you go and I'm no more problems think of
that one so you owe me good okay good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what happened what happened I don't even
know I don't even know I don't even know
okay I don't know what the hell just
happened but that was pretty good I
guess and scary and creepy and just
weird so I guess it was good all things
considered okay so I've got one more
game here I've given my voice a little
bit of a break as well since I come
across okay now this one's called stay
out of the house now this one's not done
but this one is not done this one
carries a similar theme to babysitter
bloodbath I am mad
in that I'm in a house and I shouldn't
be there which seems to be a common
scene in a lot of
[Music]
Howard
anger doesn't have to be something that
you lose yourself
like all things I'm experiencing in
the world they can be a tool
I will show you how to utilize oh oh I
don't know what I did
oh I know what I did okay cool I'm good
whew it's like the first game with the
nan massacre oh [ __ ] that's a problem
okay hello what would happen what would
happen if I just bow down
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] and everything's fine
hello I'm guessing I wasn't supposed to
do that no one knows I'm here
no one knows
hi okay oh right this is uncomfortable
yeah no joke yeah no joke no joke about
that huh Oh something there okay come on
give that oh god I can't read this I
must feel all I must feel all you think
that would get Appetit Deus after I
can't read that I don't think I have
time to read it either oh this is where
I was supposed to come out oh okay Oh
night shift abductor strikes again okay
that's good that's real good about that
when is he gonna notice that I'm gone
when is he gonna start coming after me
toilet lid fixed it for you boss it's
using a lot of the assets from the other
games but then again I think they
probably do that or maybe all those were
leading up to this one though okay
hammer 80 ho then why do I need a hammer
I don't know why I need a hammer can I
bash that guy in the head with a yeah
maybe
whoa Zach gasps oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
[ __ ] how'd you get to can play it
back and [ __ ] like a hammer or two days
remain like the fake
[Music]
okay okay try to find my way out again
huh boy okay all right I don't know why
I'm here I don't know what I did wrong I
think that all of these games the three
games that I've been playing are somehow
connected which is odd but it's pretty
clear at the same time there's some
story that's being told I know when they
were developing this game they also made
the other ones as like small additional
games I don't know why hey let me
restart this because I think I [ __ ] it
up okay now through the hole in this
time I'm not gonna be a stupid [ __ ]
and I'm not gonna move where I shouldn't
go give me the lighter give me what I
need to close this up let's not leave
any suspicions oh wait it's not there
why is it not there
what I said out there well that's weird
oh okay alright then I guess we don't
have to worry about that for some reason
or another I have the paperclip nods
right there okay so so what about that
what's the sound meter for but that
wasn't locked before
no this is weird a rock okay well I got
another rock I don't know where to throw
the rock got some sleeping know what
that was so I need to bash this no I
need to bash that's good news don't do
that
so he unlocked the door and now I can
move on that's my understanding anyway
wasn't there a button for an alarm too
wasn't there an alarm button somewhere
over here like in one of these other
rooms I could've sworn I remember seeing
one it's simple but now that it's
unlocked I should be able to yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
let me go get the hammer let me go get
the hammer radar I don't need the radar
oh god they've randomized where the
things are
they've randomized a lot of things about
this okay
there's no gas pumping out of that thing
anymore which I suppose might be a good
thing but I'm not a Harmison sure what's
good and what's bad anymore hammer
there's no hammer then I forgot I don't
know this guy love you corpse
how long have they been here too long
probably oh [ __ ] hippity-hop right over
it
easy-peasy and nothing interesting here
oh hi okay a rock good another rock I
don't know why I need another rock but
I've got another rock I mouse rat or
whatever you are a pile of flesh yeah
probably not
probably not human flesh probably not
there's locked squish not opening that
Wow Kim metal door ah the metal door
like like babysitter era like um like
the power drill massacre that's what
that's like
Oh God into the basement okay yeah I
think that's the room that I was in
before but I didn't know I don't know
where this guy is right now string of
convenience or abductions baffled police
yeah they baffle me too because I have
no idea where I am
[ __ ] okay there's an electrical box
screwed shut so we need to find a screw
oh no this was not the house okay so I
need to find like a screwdriver and wire
cutters probably oh boy that is enough
power okay let me go do something
drastic here I'm gonna trigger this
because hopefully he's gonna he's gonna
come out of something yeah and once he
comes out of somewhere then maybe I can
get into wherever he came out of what
was he coming out of that grid on the
door was I think yeah
No No how did you no no no no two days
remain huh well I don't have two days
unfortunately okay I'm gonna consider
this one on cause from not done not done
with this one because I've barely
scratched the surface of this one
but unfortunately my voice is just to
thrash to be able to continue that one
but this has been a long three scary
games so if you want to play any of
these games I'll put them down in the
description below they were all through
puppet combos patreon which is how
they're funding their projects which is
a really cool way to do it because
they're an indie developer I think
they're just a dream team of three
people and they're funding their games
just from patreon and they're really
cool games they're terrifying they're
horrifying
they're absolutely scary and that's cool
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
let me know what you thought down in the
comments below if you want some cool
clothing know that jacksepticeye and I
have made a clothing brand called cloak
with some really cool comfortable stuff
I'm wearing one right now you can check
it out at cloak brand.com if you want to
see for yourself and thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]